excuse me that was part just to fill
that out Part B is just to graph it so
if I had to choose a scale I'm gonna
have to go from 1 up to 5 so that's on
thee which axis would that be horizontal
vertical horizontal is it's the
independent very much let's do that and
I'm gonna have to go up to 750 maybe 8
will be a nice round number to choose
okay
so let's put those markings in 1 2 3
[Music]
okay now just like before to get a
straight line you only really need two
points you don't have to put every
single one on if you've marked out all
of your spots on here nicely then if
you've picked the two points accurately
then it will pass through all the other
points as well if you connect them up so
on mine I should find a dollar-fifty is
gonna be three-quarters the way up here
that'll be a dollar fifty for a single
pack of pencils and seven dollars fifty
is gonna be around there so that
corresponds to five packs now with your
ruler if you've chosen these points
correctly I should be able to join them
up but I'm gonna do more than just try
them I'm actually going to go a little
bit further down to the end here to
include a point that I didn't have in my
table and it's actually a really
important point which is why I'm
highlighting you so when you join these
are number one you should be able to
confirm if you bro your line up to where
all of your other points should
correspond to for example I went to two
you should find that is equivalent to
the other values that you've got you can
confirm those really quickly but
secondly have a look at where this graph
begins
what is that spot it's zero zero it's
the origin right now this is really
important because it's a feature of all
direct linear variation situations every
single one passes through the origin
because if you've got none of one thing
if you didn't buy any pencils then it's
not going to cost you any money or
whatever kinds of two quantities you're
comparing okay Part C we've actually
already done this the constant of
variation is the same as the constant of
proportionality we've got it it's what
if we say dollar 50 right the linear
equation for P in terms of M okay so
remember over here I said every
variation equation will look like this
just with the appropriate choices of
pronumeral so which one's X and which
one
why is it is this one gonna be number of
pencils or is this one going to be
number of pencils okay X will be the
number of pencils because is X is what
we usually label as the independent
variable on which the other one depends
so we're about to part de the linear
equation will look like this if this is
going to be n it'll be one dollar fifty
times n which leaves P the price over on
the left hand side there's my linear
equation find the cost of nine packs of
pencils because I now have the equation
I don't need to rely on the graph I can
go straight to the equation and get it
precisely so I can say P equals when N
equals nine dollar fifty times nine
I think that's thirteen dollars 5000 me
if I'm doing my numbers right 1350
before I write it down yep there's the
price I should put some units on there
so I'll put dollar P 13 dollars 50s I'm
going in reverse order and we've been
tripped up by this before I noticed in
the AP force we had a bit of trouble
with this you can have a formula we give
you so many formulas on the four new
data sheet the key is do you know how to
use them if the price for n packs of
pencils is twenty seven dollars find n
so where am I going to put $27 $27 is a
price so I'm going to substitute it for
where pay belongs so it's on the left
hand side which is a little bit weird so
I'm gonna get this 27 equals a dollar
fifty times M one of the ways you can
know that you've done this right is
because you still have this Pro numeral
here which is the one that you've been
asked to find well it had better be
there because I want to get a final line
of N equals something or other now I
notice just by coincidence 27 is exactly
double the number I got in the previous
question yeah that I think that's just
so therefore how many pencils without
even using a calculator there should be
18 and of course you can double-check
that 27 divided by 1.5 gives you that
number okay
direct linear variation is pretty
straightforward the numbers are really
easy their values easy and their shapes
are easy too if you were to graph them
okay so this is just sort of getting us
warmed up for when we have direct
nonlinear variation and we have arm
indirect variation which we will come to
in am-5 okay